we were heading to our first stop today
in our tour in Rome we're heading into
the Vatican little orientation so that
is the church
that's the because I'm Peters no my has
a very everything is so big and so old I
also probably should have known this the
Vatican is its own country like I didn't
know that neither maybe at one point I
know I feel like that's something that I
learned at some point in my life so I
feel like I'm relearning a lot of things
right now
that's our tour guide and she's moving
the world right now
this globe was built in 1990 it's a real
fresh piece here that there is so much
stuff
this is unbelievable
so fun fact that we just learned a lot
of people needs that are covering up
parts of the BOD but what they're by
different folks because they didn't like
the nudity they'd either use a leaf or
they would have to cut it off that's
uncomfortable I also lost my group
they are most of these were actually
excavated and originally in their
natural form they were painted my colors
but obviously that didn't last
looks a lot better with my eyes
it looks better with my eyes
it's probably over there on one of those
shelves I think they would have put the
pieces
so on here
change happen pretty soon but can't film
or take pictures in there because in fun
fact another one I don't remember what
she said but the Sistine Chapel they
filmed a 10-year documentary and whoever
filmed that documentary has the
copyrights for the photos and videos of
Sistine Chapel so no one else can win
the helmet
John just crossed the border of the
Vatican in Rome we're now in Rome two
seconds ago here in the Vatican that's
crazy
Gela girls where is it the joke dummy I
got the joke it was funny get a pinch oh
please don't I my son
I've assembly to see in person the video
and photos don't even do it justice
When in Rome that's what I said before I
took the absence shot she did think the
shopping is like it actually makes them
what kind of one should get tonight
someone else is picking Jen ask what
kind of wine we should get I decided not
to film myself eating because the last
video I think I've filmed every time we
had a snack it was like 25 million times
uh I say that brings this tour to it and
we saw so many amazing things it's so
beautiful here and just so much history
and so much stuff that I actually just
don't know enough about feel very very
uneducated ciao bella ciao bella oh
goodness I'm hot I'm gonna take a nap
see you later hi
holy moly we're here aunt Susie's here
how did how did this all happen we're
not sure don't ask questions